[Música]
eu queria começar essa conversa com
vocês pedindo que vocês fizessem essa
pergunta assim como é que vocês se vêem
amanhã
acho que são a uma pergunta interessante
que eu tento me fazer todos os anos até
mesmo pra preparar o meu futuro né e
antes de ir pro futuro queria que a
gente fosse um pouquinho no passado que
eu acho que tem tudo a ver com o que
somos hoje né
então na minha formação eu tive uma mãe
dona de casa tá que tinha uma ideia
completamente higienista e fez eu e meu
irmão se dissermos atleta como boa dona
de casa na época nos ensinava nos levava
para as atividades físicas etc e meu pai
que depois de um tempo ela se tornou
advogado mas era um militar da
aeronáutica tá é autodidata
trabalhava como mecânico de voo e essa é
a foto retrata bem porque eu me lembro
que eu ia na base aérea brincava nos
aviões os aniversários lá de casa tinham
isso e ele sempre tentou passar pra
gente nessas curiosidades da tecnologia
o pai também era dono de uma oficina e
foi aí que tive o primeiro aprendizado
não vou dizer assim meu filho perceba o
seu pai seja diferente você percebe o
homem tem 17 profissões e consegue 18
necessidades então foi uma coisa que eu
entendi depois de um tempo que a gente
precisa focar é muito mais nas nossas
atividades e aí é mas como eu falei ele
é um é realmente um autodidata um cara
aqui um pouco à frente do tempo dele
eu sempre me interessei muito por essa
parte da tecnologia
quem é da década de 90 que vai tá
olhando pra cá e não entendem não
lembrar de algumas coisas mas o telefone
por exemplo que dali em cima é quem é
que colocou a linha telefônica do
imposto de renda teve alguém aqui já
colocou ela no telefone no imposto de
renda
assim quem tem telefone fixo hoje eu não
tenho mais né
olha a pressão ali atrás que tem tá
eu não tenho mais telefone fixo e acho
que a grande maioria não tem porque
parece não fazer mais sentido e quem tem
provavelmente é porque está no pacote da
net a net não libera seu telefone fixo
né
então assim o aparelho de fax tivesse
rede social
acho que meu pai que é compartilhado em
todas porque ele tinha orgulho de dizer
comprei um fax para que serve a enviar o
documento para quem para quem faz nem
todo mundo tinha fax
então ele viajava pouco documento mas
sim o fax né
eu tinha lá os disquetes né que alguns
são vendo ali aquele bichinho quadrado
no canto da tela
tá ele tinha um é capacidade fantástica
de armazenamento 1400 caracteres eu não
estou enganado
o pen drive o primeiro que eu comprei em
2013 armazenava 128 megas cabe mais ou
menos 40 fotos o que a gente deve
receber um grupo de teatro hoje né
então tudo isso da tecnologia está a a
gente vem essa tecnologia vem avançando
mas mais do que a tecnologia o
conhecimento
antigamente acreditava-se que na década
em 1912 madá mente a população
demorava cerca de 100 anos para dobrar
seu conhecimento em 1945 isso já foi
para 25 anos sem chover as evoluções
tecnológicas as evoluções que tiveram
desde essa época a gente vai checar
nisso a partir de 2015
treze meses e se acredita que em 2020
sejam 13 horas
vou mostrar pra vocês aqui o próximo
episódio a gente confirmar isso quem tem
um pt 550 roupa né aparelho de luxo hoje
em dia os celulares caem quebra e se
você jogava na parede não se esforçava
capa não existia porque se eu usasse
capa ele era um notebook e editam largo
que ele ficasse não conseguiu usar no
bolso e aí era chique porque era moda
custava caríssimo a gente usava que na
cintura se mostrando pra todo mundo
assim bonitão com o celular em um
horário mais uma pochete né
e ele demorou 24 anos para chegar nos
aparelhos que nós temos hoje eu faço uma
porta
que tempo vocês aqui algum de vocês
principalmente os mais novos pode já ter
saído de casa sem escovar os dentes mas
não saísse um celular porque é
impossível sair sem um celular porque
nós relata tudo né tá toda toda a nossa
vida
tá mas agora vamos ver o que acontecia
na internet um minuto há um ano atrás
queria que você olhar sensível que está
pequeno mas em um minuto 70 mil vídeos
70 mil horas de vídeo eram assistidas no
netflix muita coisa em 2018
são 266 horas
é por isso que a gente não consegue
enxergar locadora na cidade onde vive
simples assim e tudo isso se dá por
assim flores e explosão informacional em
1985 por exemplo nossa capacidade de
armazenamento de informação era muito
pequena hoje é infinita
esse gráfico vocês estão vendo aí deu um
chute de washigton post ele trabalha com
com aproximadamente 276 bilhões de
gigabytes hoje infinito tá tudo na nuvem
quando eu vejo um hd digital eu não
queria isso o hd externo eu sei sobre
aquele assim tudo está na nuvem
porque assim a gente compra do edital
fazer o que a gente dá cap né pra que o
paciente perdeu o computador é o backup
mas agradece sempre anda junto com o
computador quando o computador phd
também perto tudo que eu tenho né
a gente coloca normalmente na nuvem que
a gente deixa mais prático tá
e esse avanço é essa capacidade de
guardar informação né
auxilia no avanço da tecnologia que
consegue proporcionar pra gente um nível
de informação maior certo gerando maior
comunicação tão essa comunicação as
pessoas interagirem na internet elas
acabam tendo inovações mais
colaborativas e trabalho em conjunto
manter esse círculo virtuoso de avanço
da tecnologia maior capacidade de gerar
informações maiores inovações maior
avanço
elogia e por aí vai tá esse ciclo se
mantém firme e bem sólido neste processo
e aí a gente chega no clube é o que foi
o criador da singularity universo se
chama de um crescimento exponencial
por isso que as as coisas hoje elas
desenvolvem tão rápido mas ele informa
que o crescimento exponencial e tem 6 10
primeiro as coisas se digitalizam ela
decepcionou no primeiro momento
depois vem algo disruptivo ele
desmaterializa desmagnetiza e se
democratiza e aí eu trouxe pra vocês um
exemplo do gps o primeiro gps criado com
estava 3 mil dólares nos estados unidos
não era uma uma plataforma usual tá é
você tinha códigos né e e isso acabava
não sendo fácil de pessoas comuns
utilizarem então ele acabou
decepcionando os mapas sumiram
funcionários gps's mas só profissionais
conseguiram usar até que chegou alguém
com ideias objetiva e criou aquele gps
que nós conhecemos né com tela
touchscreen
alguns tinham tv joguinhos eles tinham
os hot point lá que a gente colocava a
farmácia ele identificava farmácia mais
próxima e se sair já ficaram mais
acessíveis né porque ele já vê o mais
barato de um hardware diferente
depois esses materializaram e foram
virados aplicativos app peso celulares
também ficaram desmoralizados passar a
custar menos porque eu não precisava
mais do hardware a pena do software né e
hoje que a gente tem é a democratização
disso né
nós temos o ese que quase praticamente
todos vocês devem ter usado já tá que é
totalmente colaborativo é que a gente
usa no dia a dia tá pra coisa esse ano
esse século 21 e não vai ter 100 anos do
século 21 não ter 20 mil anos justamente
por conta desse crescimento exponencial
tá então é muita informação é muita
mudança ea gente precisa tá preparado
pra isso pra entender o que é que vai
ser esta manhã o que essas mudanças vão
gerar nossas vidas
é o que essas mudanças vão gerar no
campo dos empregos da saúde como vai ser
amanhã tá não trouxe dois pontos aqui
primeiro são os festivais é usuária os
esmaltes eles hoje já verificam
freqüência cardíaca já sabem a
temperatura vai identificar no futuro
sua pressão arterial isso tudo está
conectado com o seu médico tá com seu
celular que seu celular está conectado
com o seu médico que vai ter um processo
de inteligência artificial que vai
informar que você precisa visitar um
médico porque se está andando menos do
que deveria
sua pressão já está subindo sua
frequência já não está se comportando
normalmente e por conta disso já no vale
do silício temos quase mil empresas de
tecnologia relacionadas à saúde
um avanço dessa tecnologia tá por
exemplo né quem usa iphone aqui conta
compartilhada lá em casa todo mundo com
um iphone quando compartilhada
minha mulher não liga mais hamilton
quando a liga já para mandar para casa
até mesmo tem aquela já olhou lado
buscar iphone sabia que eu tô né
então essas situações mudam as relações
do dia a dia né meu pai desligar o
celular que tinha ao pt 550 desligava o
celular onde é que tá não pagar o sinal
hoje não tem mais isso aí pessoal quais
são as implicações disso na vida a gente
vai ter uma prevenção muito mais forte
tony provavelmente vai viver mais
acredita se que os bebês estão nascendo
hoje devem chegar os 145 anos
legal isso ótimo mas existem suas
complicações também vai ser a
alimentação desse mundo lá na frente se
vai na fixe as pessoas vão permanecer
muito mais vivos do que falecendo na lei
natural como é que vai ficar isso no
futuro tá com essa perspectiva as
pessoas acreditam também que em 2045
nasce o homem imortal
imortal como a gente já vi alguns filmes
né mas o imortal é relacionada
patologias está relacionada a doenças
lógico que o acidente se a gente não vai
conseguir evitar com relação aos
empregos
a gente também vai ter mudanças então o
meio da pirâmide ali as médias
habilidade estão sendo substituídas
os operadores de máquinas já estão sendo
substituídos ligações de telemarketing
agora ele recebe ligação entre a nato eo
robô
a gente entra na internet lá no banco no
seu banco ou eu sou maxwell supervisor
de investimentos o que você gostaria de
fazer hoje
então já tem um bonequinho de
inteligência artificial que faz os
primeiros processos
tá alguns empregos
eles também vão crescer então o que o
que se entende hoje a relação dos
empregos é que a 1 o meio do processo as
médias habilidades dependendo da sua
capacidade adaptativa porque na vida não
é mais forte que sobrevive é quem mais
se adapta é quem tem a maior capacidade
de se adaptar determinadas situações
então essas mudanças no campo dos
empregos as pessoas vão ter que flutuar
para as maiores habilidades ou para as
melhores habilidades tá
são profissões de cuidado é de que é
relacionados à saúde
elas tendem a aumentar o que a gente viu
anteriormente
as pessoas vão viver mais vou viver mais
na terceira idade precisam de mais
cuidados
então isso tende a aumentar tá e aí é eu
não gosto muito de uma frase da martha
gabriel que diz o seguinte isso gera
muito medo é a questão da substituição
por robôs
então se você não quer ser substituído
por um robô pare de agir como roubo
tá na hora de agir como um robô para de
fazer o seu trabalho como um robô
há dois anos atrás eu falei pra vocês no
início ea influência grande na minha mãe
e há dois anos atrás eu virei triatleta
tá essa é a foto da minha chegada não
era o meia de maceió 70.3 esse ano eu
fiz o irã e as seis horas e 2 minutos
1900 metros nadando 90 que vamos pagar
os 21 quilômetros correndo
é um profissional faça quatro horas uma
prova dessa certo eu fiz para 6 2
mas para mim é uma vitória os meus
objetivos foram cumpridos na primeira
prova em novembro do ano passado a prova
desse ano eu baixei 54 minutos
perdi peso evoluir
quando eu cruzei se pórtico sensação de
dever cumprido e de meta alcançada era
gigante assim uma coisa indescritível é
na minha vida e quando cruzei no momento
da corrida que é o que eu mais sofri pra
fazer até por conta desse meu pezinho
aqui eu pensava em tudo que eu tive que
viver ali
de tudo que eu tive que treinar para
chegar ali de tudo que eu tive que nadar
correr para lá vai estar ali e não era
só isso eu preciso dar atenção à minha
família eu preciso dar atenção meus
amigos eu precisei trabalhar
afinal o esporte é caro tá então quando
vejo tudo isso eu entendo que o futuro é
hoje que a gente precisa viver cada vez
mais o presente e que cada dia que passa
a gente fica mais ansioso olhando para o
futuro e esquece de viver o que a gente
tem agora esquece de aproveitar o que a
gente tem agora e todas as áreas da
nossa vida não existe morte súbita
a gente se mata lentamente todos os dias
não existe um relacionamento acabou de
repente ele foi morrendo aos poucos
então assim pra que vocês vivam estejam
nesse novo amanhã a pena viver o
presente
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]